e é eu morro de medo de uma coisa né
embora passei essa 20 anos assim deve
ter tido sei lá nem perdi a conta de
quantos alunos nos últimos 20 anos e
eventos como esse mas eu morro de medo
de microfone que não seja auricular para
todo mundo ver que minha mão tremendo e
meu coração tá saindo pela boca e isso
contextualizar como se não tivesse
decorado né com a primeira vez que eu
dei um beijo na minha esposa e tem a ver
com por quê que todo mundo precisa
aprender sobre marketing é eu tava no
cinema com ela e ela percebeu ela falou
assim nossa o coração tá quase pulando
né a gente dá um beijo dá para perceber
não sabia que dá para perceber
internamente o coração da pessoa estava
passando pela boca mas ela comentou aí
se ela verbalizou eu fiquei um pouco
mais nervoso pois dias mas a história é
a seguinte ela entrou no meu carro e aí
quando ele entrou no meu carro eu liguei
o som e cara colocou alanis morissette
tô com augustinho lane aí ela olhou pra
mim eu olhei para ela a gente sempre
olhou ela falou eu não acredito que você
gosta de alanis aí ou você tá brincando
é só que eu odeio alanis
e não eu botei no cd o cd da alanis
porque ela tirou curte você sabe numa
curta pessoa fã de alguma coisa então na
verdade eu só estudei meu público alvo
assim e por isso
tu é trevo
e por isso eu queria perguntar para
vocês qual é o nome da atividade que
pega um produto que é ruim no caso assim
não comparando que eu seja um produto
ruim mas vendo esse produto ruim como se
ele fosse bom enganando o consumidor
você sabe qual o nome da atividade que é
capaz de maquiar produtos coisas que são
ruins e vender gato por lebre você sabe
o nome pois é não é mar que tinha
estelionato tá nome de estelionato a o
market não é isso olha o marketing é
claro que não bebê isso aí na marketing
não faz isso com mais de verdadeiro
objetivo ele produzir valores e para os
valores a mão somando todos os valores
não é produzir dinheiro produzir valor é
produzir dinheiro que é um dos seus
valores para mim é um dos menores
valores option rom calma meu jovem tô
falando de valor né valor é paz de
espírito quem não gostaria de ter muita
paz de espírito com um negócio que criou
com quem gostaria então você tem um
negócio tem cinco 100 funcionários ganha
muito dinheiro mas você não dorme a
noite você sente de rivotril ritalina eu
tô brigando com tapete e aí vocês é isso
isso não é produção de valor então o
marketing bem feito ele é capaz de
produzir valor valor mesmo falar nosso
um dos valores grandes para ter sucesso
aí você participar espírito o outro
valor você reconhecimento reconhecimento
todo mundo a sua volta seus funcionários
chamarem o público amar gostar de você
eu tava pensando nisso né tá mais um
show de stand-up ele tem uma coisa séria
mas olha só ou imagina por dave grohl
cara o ápice de que adianta você vender
1 milhão de milhões de cds e shows
ganhar um monte de dinheiro deve ser
muito legal também pelo reconhecimento
por um beatle imagina o que tu chegar
para você e falar assim ei cara seu
trabalho sensacional e falando em inglês
é mais emoção e ele fala redwood aí
então
eu imaginei obrigado a
eu pensei nas ontem à noite aí aí sono
cara eu olho para minha filhinha de 4
anos e penso cara olha aí disse isso
para mim é muito sucesso eu recusei
assim o emprego para ganhar quatro cinco
vezes mais que eu ganho hoje justamente
porque quando eles colocaram a condição
eles falaram você minha filha tava com
um ano eles falaram que vai ter que ser
alta executiva viajar o brasil inteiro
pegar avião todo dia eu falei não não
tem nenhum preço do ano passar um tempo
com a minha filha então valor a isso que
adianta sair de um mega empresário não
tiver tempo para família não tiver não
consegui ter um sono tranquilo quem é
que não pagaria muito para ter sono um
bom sono né idosos perceberam bom a
experiência experiências fantásticas é
também experiências tanto relação a seus
negócio imagina todo mundo fala nossa
sua empresa mais inovadora o seu negócio
é o melhor sabe é seus funcionários
também ter experiências muito boas lá
todos os seus através da experiência que
você viu
o negócio é muito boas que que adianta
uma rotina muito enjoada muito chata
fazer o que você não ama que se encher
de dinheiro aí o objetivo do marketing é
produzir lucro não é para mim você tem
que fazer um marketing muito bem feito
para conseguir produzir esses valores
imagina deixar um legado que bacana mas
na sua empresa deixar um legado sabe eu
prefiro isso de verdade mesmo eu prefiro
ser um professor que quis só abraçado
pelos alunos que os alunos gostam de mim
que falem bem de mim e que no futuro
quem sabe nós vamos ficar mais aqui que
lembrem com carinho do que chegar e eu
tava que tá ganhando maior salário em
algum lugar e isso para mim não é o
sucesso você para pessoa é mas só que
antigamente o que uma palestra para mim
padrão que eu falava isso eu acabei de
falar eu falava que o objetivo do
marketing ele parte da empresa a empresa
tem que ter produzir valores para ela e
para todos têm que holder todos os seus
públicos de interesse e tela teria que
produzir valor os seus funcionários para
seus fornecedores para os acionistas é
pros clientes a glicose
o resultado correlatos para todo mundo
que tá a volta eu falava que isso era
papel da empresa hoje eu não falo eu
falo que todo mundo de certa forma ele é
uma empresa então funcionar ele não
deixa de ser uma marca um cliente não
deixa de ser uma marca ele não tem que
ser um bom cliente então todo mundo hoje
tem ferramentas tem aprendizar você pode
virar em alguns em algumas plataformas
digitais e comprar por 20reais cursos
completos de marketing digital curso
completo de alex pode comprar cursos de
desenho você pode desenvolver sabe fazer
disciplinas nem que seja como ouvinte ou
cooperativas na universidade precisar né
de marketing tem muita o possibilidade
de aprendizagem para as pessoas se
potencializar e como marcas mas elas
estão os potencializando como marca para
ganhar dinheiro elas não estão
preocupadas em produzir falou
bom então hoje eu vou ensinar alguns
truques para que você possa fortalecer a
sua marca e produzir valores para o
mundo
a unidade gerência de dados comunidade
tá todo mundo usando muito machine
learning deita data science isso é muito
interessante alguns países inclusive
como canadá tão pisando no freio então
voltando atrás não tão querendo mais as
inteligência de dados todas né mas as
pessoas esqueceram que trabalho de marca
é trabalho orgânico é todos nós temos o
melhor vídeo game do mundo assim você
parar para pensar é todo mundo fica aí
pensando nossa olha que gráfico eu tenho
universo digital que foi criado aqui
dentro mais que a nossa própria vida né
nosso próprio cérebro sim mas a gente
não aprendeu a lidar com softwares in a
gente só destrói o planeta só vivo de
forma competitiva é a segunda questão
aqui é ampliar a percepção curso da
sensorialidade maioria das pessoas que
eu conheço e pensa em publicidade por
exemplo elas pensam dentro de um
retângulo elas pensam publicidade
comunicação marketing áudio visual e não
é marca tem cheiro marca atenção
em muitas livrarias quebraram e elas
falam que quebraram por causa da venda
online mas elas não souberam competir
com a venda online hoje você chega numa
livraria não tem ninguém que entende
livro não tem ninguém que aperto sua mão
que senta para conversar com você sobre
o autor
e é eu falo tá organizar da marca para
ver por exemplo qual é a marca de certa
forma que quase todo mundo mais ama é a
mãe né ou pai né os pais assim eles têm
cheiro eles tentam de voz sabe é tatu é
sei lá o tímbrico então assim a gente
trabalhar a marca da gente por isso que
uma das minhas principais ferramentas de
marketing que eu trabalho assim colchão
ferramenta de marketing em massa bem
orgânico tá gente é o é o cafezinho por
isso eu posso minha casa aqui ó daqui
bom a carequinha tá vendo faixa preta
meu livro eu adoro tomar café com as
pessoas acho a coisa mais fantástica e
vem tomar um cafezinho que eu acho que
aproxima todo mundo você quer mandar um
currículo um portfólio para alguém uma
uma proposta de negócios manda um manda
um ficar um café você vai fechar um
negócio para muito mais fácil fala sobre
outros assuntos
o
e é experiência do usuário em todos os
pontos de contato botei aqui algumas
mídias sociais infelizmente eu por
exemplo com o livro eu vendo livro o
brasil inteiro mesmo perfeição em
vitória agora já até recebi uma proposta
para lançar dois livros da editora
nacional que é que eu prefiro de
negócios mas eu lancei um livro todo
independente e eu consegui vender o
brasil inteiro usando essas plataformas
todas só que tem outros pontos de
contato tem o whatsapp um deles um cara
viu meu vídeo no youtube e ele comentou
no youtube nossa eu queria comprar o seu
livro aí eu vi pelas redes sociais do
telefone do cara entrei pelo whatsapp e
falei olha você comentou meu canal no
youtube eu quero que você eu não
acredito começou a falar comigo então
assim tem outros canais para gente ir as
marcas elas acham que os únicos pontos
de contato são o adoro o anúncio de
jornal e o ponto de venda e não é tem
muito ponto de contato para você falar
com cliente pessoas comuns tem esse
ponto de contato comece pelo porquê
também a é um livro do simon sinek fala
isso mas eu já só vou falar também algo
que era
a visão guanaes conquistado famoso que
falava enquanto ele choram vendo lenços
fala nossa eu acho isso tão míope
marketing sabe porque enquanto ele chora
você vende lenço então você se vê como
uma fábrica de lenço flávia se todo
mundo parar de usar lenço lançou outra
tecnologia você quebra você tem que
entender o seguinte qual o motivo das
pessoas chorarem eu essas pessoas choram
vendo rivotril vendo ritalina vendo
clínicas de conforto clínicas é aulas de
yoga parque de diversão conselhos
matrimoniais livros de autoajuda eu
tenho que eu queria todo o ecossistema
do choro para tentar explorar a semana
do ócio o cara fala r$10000 não colchão
é mas é um colchão com mola americana
não cara esses 10 mil reais é para que o
seu casamento seja sal para caminhar
você deu uma palestra bem dado você não
vai ficar com sono lá mal humorado né a
mão suando então assim a
15 fortaleza supermercado em vez de
destruir o concorrente hoje é o seu
exemplo aqui né esses três aqui né a
gente vai fazendo algumas coisinhas
junto né assim é esses três aí por
exemplo eles não são concorrentes eles
fortalecem o mercado o pessoal da
comédia adora fazer isso também as
agências tem que ver por exemplo a as
empresas de fast-food móvel miopia que
tem é você achar que mac donald's burger
king são concorrentes eles definam seus
melhores amigos eles deveriam assim
deveria ou não né não comigo lá no
market mas ele deveriam proteger o
próprio mercado que eu concorrente deles
academia de ginástica ou a gente
concorrente principal deles é o
nutricionista então se une as pessoas
que estão a sua volta fazer a mesma
coisa para você deve ser muito bom chef
de cozinha podem ser admirados pelos
outros
bom então fica adianta por exemplo isso
aí são algumas ferramentas que eu botei
no livro agora no segundo eu tô botando
um monte mais assim mas são algumas
ferramentas que a gente faz presente
apolinho valderie lápis creio com
marketing de conteúdo inbound é se o e o
ex co-branding né trabalho broadcast
mesmo processo ele é que rir né então
assim tem muita muita ferramenta de
marketing para trabalhar à noite
ferramenta de comunicação muita
ferramenta de estratégia só que de que
adianta você dominar todas as
ferramentas para ter um sucesso se 86
por cento dos brasileiros por exemplo
sofrem com algum tipo de transtorno
mental seja principalmente ansiedade e
depressão
e agora sabe meu raciocínio para que
serve mesmo assim né é
e aí
em todas as pessoas hoje podem eu suas
próprias marcas todo mundo
eu gostei muito com a fornecer que eu
fiz mas com marketing voltado para a
produção de valores sabe a todo mundo
hoje quer te marca gente você abre uma
mídia social com acabei de descobrir me
julgue chamada tik tok né que é tipo um
pornô softbase mas não acho que toca é
um instagram mais de urgente mais lindo
talvez em linda no no padrão que
inventaram né mas é eu não sei de
consertar mas o tic toc é uma mídia
social em que pessoas comuns tem 100 mil
seguidores sabe sem viu é audiência
maior do que mídia de massa local dos
anos 80 e são muitas pessoas e muitas
muitas pessoas comuns são as pessoas
estão se vendendo como marcas e a minha
grande questão é imagina se tá todo
mundo se vendendo como marca hoje não é
mais a igreja católica que inventou o
poder da propaganda e depois foi a
revolução industrial as grandes
indústrias é que passaram a poder pagar
para fazer uma grande propaganda hoje em
dia todo mundo pode
a forma é semiprofissional ou busca aos
poucos crescer de uma forma profissional
usar o com os canais de comunicação
estão tentando se promover como marca
mas já que todo mundo e muitos de vocês
porque não produzir se promover de uma
forma real em vez de buscar sua louca
buscar aquele valores todo o quê que
vocês não buscam por exemplo ganhar
muito dinheiro mas não muito dinheiro e
sucesso na carreira para poder dormir
bem não tem que tomar tanto remédio né e
pode ser por exemplo aqui fazer isso né
se aluno os melhores professores
melhores clientes melhores torcedores
melhores celebridades sua marca só vai
elevando em torno disso e as pessoas
fonte indicando para as coisas vão te
chamando é um tomando mais cafezinho com
você e aí você consegue se promover por
isso que eu acho que uma das melhores
formas hoje assim melhores né e
unicamente todo mundo me matar de salvar
o mundo é com marcos mas não martin
baseado no lucro macho baseado na
promoção promoção de valor se todo mundo
trabalhar seu marte preto
o valor para si e para os outros talvez
a gente conseguir para um caminho bom
ó tá vendo gente conquista dinheiro se
for um importante para você pedir é bom
para você pagar um plano de saúde bom
também um colchão de qualidade para não
quebrar sua coluna um curso de yoga
essas coisas assim também né mas também
a paz de espírito na experiência
conforto e o reconhecimento obrigado
e aí